[Music]  kingsman world's finest tailor  but now we're going into the spy  business  very clever based on true events  this will not be a war of  [Music]  weakness throwing arm  strength  started world war one  the super spy  mata  strength  screen presence  weakness  scarves do you forget your manners  guilty as charged  have a crazed monkey  respiratory strength  and weaknesses  [Music]  you'll have to see it for yourself  it's good now  yes on december 22nd our enemies think  we are gentlemen  it's time to remind them  what the kingsmen are  [Music]  nobility is born  in blood  [Music]  [Music]  boys are always so messy  the king's man only in theaters december  22nd  [Music]  you